the Joe Rogan experience what the hell's
load is doing these days like they keep
coming out with all these concepts and
prototypes but then nothing ever seems
to be actually happening or coming out I
don't know they had that little car you
know I guess it's that one is that the
one the really little one that they had
at least I drove it one day I was like
what will you have a [ __ ] pair of
Chipmunks running the the engine with a
one of those hamster wheels but then
even like last year at the quail we were
up there showing a car they debuted a
concept that was lovely was kick-ass but
from what I heard at what's-his-name
Behar they're making such a disgusting
amount of money and licensing like
keychains and [ __ ] that like the
core even the engineering Tier one
engineering aspect of Lotus and then the
production they're like [ __ ] that that's
complicated wait a minute they make
their money off a little keychains yeah
from what I've been told that's what's
kept Lotus in business over the last 10
years
Lotus keychains kid just merch just
whatever watches mercs bags whatever
[ __ ] that anyone wants to put the Lotus
name on there's selling licenses left to
right but they're not selling cars I
don't think they have anything in
production right that's so weird and
they've shown like more concepts than
multinational car companies well I know
Matt Farah reviewed that rear engine or
the mid-engine one that they have and
said it was awesome it's beautiful car
but you don't see them you never see
them I think they're one of those
interesting companies that like kind of
like a Malcolm Bricklin situation of
like just was that dude Malcolm Bricklin
so one of the best car books ever that
John you know Johnnie Lieberman right
yes dear friend Johnny had recommended
it's called the worst car ever built
and it's the story of the Hugo oh it's a
fast read it is absolutely hysterical
those shenanigans and [ __ ] show around
that car and behind all of it was
Malcolm Bricklin who's like the PT
Barnum of the automotive industry the
amount of stories and stuff this guy is
lived through and caused and gotten away
with is insane but like the
go the cars were like late they were
gonna debut at the LA Auto Show and they
realize like oh [ __ ] we don't have booth
models or anything what are we gonna do
so Malcolm Bricklin in this story goes
that he drove around downtown LA and
just where are the prostitutes where the
[ __ ] hang out around here went over in
like hired a bunch of the girls -
they're like could you put on something
a little more tame and like be here at
this time for these days just like run
the show and be their booth models and
rep the cars but like the cars is that
came out of the container had
disassembled themselves and transit like
and just on and on and on
shenanigans is hysterical but that book
is so [ __ ] funny I've never heard of
that before that's interesting
[Applause]